hoy dedicamos este espacio para tratar
la situación del fundador de wikileaks
julian assange que se encuentra
encarcelado en la prisión británica de
alta seguridad de belmarsh a la espera
de su posible extradición a eeuu en
territorio estadounidense enfrenta
cargos por violar presuntamente la ley
de espionaje a raíz de la revelación de
información clasificada sobre las
actuaciones de eeuu en la guerra de
afganistán e irak de ser condenado
podría asumir más de 170 años de cárcel
y para analizar este caso hablamos con
el juez español baltasar garzón quien
ejerce como coordinador de la defensa
internacional de julian assange también
nos acompaña en nuestra mesa de trabajo
rosa pérez más de euros a la bienvenida
a feliz mañana del lunes buenos días
raúl señor garzón un placer saludarle
quisiera empezar preguntándole por qué
defiende usted que el señor julian
assange es objeto de una persecución
política por parte sobre todo de eeuu
por qué
es evidente que eeuu se están aplicando
extraterritorialmente
una legislación por primera vez en la
historia a un periodista que ha
extranjero que ha publicado
fuera de eeuu y que en ningún caso se
puede probar que han tenido acceso
la información
sensible extraída por el de ningún tipo
de organismo o servicio de inteligencia
etcétera aparte de esto todo el
desarrollo de este proceso está
claramente motivado por
política y por acciones políticas como
se ha demostrado con la interferencia
constante y permanente de los servicios
de inteligencia en todo lo que ha sido
el periodo en el que elena sanz estuvo
refugiado en la embajada de quad core en
londres y las interferencias
respecto del propio equipo de defensa
ahora señor garzón le pregunto cómo cree
que será el juicio de julian assange en
el caso de ser extraditado a eeuu
resulta evidente para la defensa que el
trato no puede ser en ni independiente
ni igualitario porque hay una serie de
prejuicios establecidos contra julian
assange que han sido manifestados
reiteradamente por autoridades
norteamericanas del más alto nivel
y por
tanto diplomáticos como el senadores
como congresistas en las que incluso
algunos pedían la aplicación de la pena
de muerte al respecto de julian assange
no hemos tenido acceso al material de
defensa en el proceso que lleva ya casi
12 años ante un gran jurado bajo las más
estrictas
medidas de secreto por tanto la
situación de julian en un proceso en
eeuu sería altamente improbable que
respondiera a un
principio de igualdad y de
proporcionalidad y de un proceso con las
debidas garantías y precisamente en
relación a este proceso que podría
enfrentar a julian assange en eeuu fue
precisamente el departamento de justicia
de eeuu bajo el mandato del expresidente
trump quien imputó a assange a los
cargos por supuesta violación de la ley
de espionaje ustedes esperaban que con
la llegada de un tratar la casa blanca
particularmente de joe biden eeuu
retirará estos cargos
no no esperábamos de todas formas si
solicitamos como han hecho muchas
personas instituciones organizaciones
humanitarias de derechos humanos que han
pedido hemos pedido que eso ocurriera
pero la esperanza no era
exactamente como un elemento que jugará
a nuestra a nuestro favor se trata de
los servicios de inteligencia y no
países como eeuu tienen mucha fuerza los
mismos y se trata de una agresión a un
periodista que no tiene demasiada
explicación si no es motivada por esa
acción de estos servicios y sea una
administración u otra del tema de
inteligencia en estados unidos es casi
tabú para para todos y tienen la misma
el mismo desarrollo y aplicación
nosotros creo que hemos acreditado esa
presentación
y ella actuación ilícita por parte de
los propios servicios de inteligencia no
ya en lo que es el contenido de las
publicaciones de wikileaks sino orden
propio desarrollo del ejercicio de
defensa de julian assange durante la
período en los siete años que estuvo en
la embajada de ecuador en londres de
modo que a pesar de todo esto sigue
adelante el proceso cambiando normas
cambiando la petición inicial que era de
un solo cargo luego ese aumento a 17 más
fin toda una serie de circunstancias que
no auguran precisamente que haya un
cambio en la administración sea uno u
otro lo plante de la casona claro
precisamente en este aumento de los
cargos que justo ahora comenta van por
ahí 2013 la prensa estadounidense reveló
que el departamento de justicia de eeuu
no sabía cómo imputar al señor assange a
los cargos por espionaje y no hacerlo al
mismo tiempo contra los medios de
comunicación que revela en ese momento
también las informaciones de wikileaks
como el 'new york times' sin ir más
lejos cómo es que ahora se han podido
hacer esta diferencia y también
aprovecho para hacerle otra pregunta en
esta misma formulación qué opina de la
posición adoptada por estos grandes
medios de comunicación que en su momento
colaboraron con wikileaks qué postura
tienen ahora mismo ante la posible
encarcelación del señor a sancho
esta es una de las grandes paradojas de
este procedimiento
al fin del día chilena sal y wikileaks
lo que hizo fue
difundir una información que había
llegado a sus manos y lo hizo con
garantías y a través de medios masivos
de difusión los principales periódicos
del mundo se hicieron eco y como me
llevaron de forma proactiva a la
difusión de la misma y nunca han sido
molestado la respuesta está en que
evidentemente un un ataque judicial
auspiciado con pruebas más que
discutibles y obtenidas por mecanismos
bastante irregulares sería prácticamente
imposible que se aceptara a periódico el
señor está en washington vos como el
país o como lemont evidentemente esto no
hubiese sido posible finalmente han ido
a frente al elemento más débil de la
cadena y si hay que desde mi punto de
vista hay que hacer una crítica
bastante profunda en sus mismos medios
que en un momento determinado arguyeron
o dijeron que bueno julián había puesto
en peligro algunas de las fuentes eso se
ha comprobado que no es verdad nunca
antes y la prueba está en el propio
carácter de julian assange y como hasta
el día de hoy se ha negado a poner en
riesgo ningún tipo de esas fuentes y
demuestra su fortaleza tanto psíquica
como física aunque un proceso que en el
que se le ha dejado bastante solo por
parte de estos grandes medios no ha
habido grandes campañas a favor cuando
desde nuestro punto de vista
es
si le escuchamos señor garzón
si los han pinchado señor personal sí sí
cuando desde nuestro punto de vista es
uno de los casos más flagrantes y de
ataque a la libertad de expresión claro
ahora yo también voy con una pregunta
señor garzón y es que una primera
instancia la jueza británica vanessa
bright ser rechazó la extradición por
considerar que había un riesgo de que
señora sánchez se suicidara si era
extraditado a eeuu luego washington
apeló esta decisión presentando las
garantías de encarcelamiento que la
justicia británica ha aceptado también
validando así la extradición ahora en
manos de la secretaria del interior
británica le pregunto cuáles son estas
garantías presentadas por eeuu y si las
consideran ustedes suficientes además
cómo está la salud mental del señor
assange
empezando por la última parte de su
pregunta una persona que lleva privada
de libertad una situación como la que
está julian assange desde el 19 de junio
de 2012 además de la del periodo que ya
había estado en prisión tres meses en
inglaterra hasta el día de hoy no puede
estar ni física ni psíquicamente o
psicológicamente ando en plenas en
plenas funciones no porque la situación
ha sido desde una tensión impresionante
sin acceso a médicos sin posibilidad de
verdad un sensor etcétera y hoy día
pues sigue en una situación de extremada
opresión en una cárcel como es la de
alta seguridad durante mucho tiempo la
cárcel de alta seguridad de belmarsh
conocida como la a guantánamo británica
y en unas condiciones también muy muy
muy muy graves de modo que es
muy muy difícil asumir que esa que esa
situación se vaya a prolongar mucho
tiempo por esto la juez inicial de
primera instancia dijo el riesgo o
aludió al riesgo de posible suicidio en
eeuu y no entró a valorar ninguno de los
otros temas
ahora se dan estas garantías por parte
de eeuu pero lo cierto es que con
reiteradas en reiteradas ocasiones esas
mismas garantías ofrecidas en un proceso
de extradición de una forma muy
oportunista por cierto pues después se
incumple una vez que la persona sea
entregada a los eeuu el sistema judicial
norteamericano
guardabas bastante poco respecto a las
las condiciones expuestas por la
concesión o por el país que ha entregado
a la persona estamos en una fase
el ministro del interior del confis
tiene que decidir si entrega o no
entrega todas formas no ha terminado la
lucha por la libertad de julian assange
por la no es tradición y la vamos a
continuar y el señor garzón un poco para
volver a la raíz de lo que ha sido todo
este proceso le quería preguntar
finalmente qué papel ha tenido la
investigación abierta en suecia y
cerrada finalmente por la supuesta
agresión sexual cometida por julian
assage finalmente cuál ha sido el papel
de esta investigación en todo el
desencanto desencadenamiento de los
acontecimientos posteriores en el papel
desde el principio no vimos claro era
meramente instrumental era un mecanismo
para facilitar la extradición o una res
tradición desde desde suecia a eeuu o
por los acuerdos entre ambos países y
nosotros siempre dijimos desde el
principio que estábamos a favor
de el juicio a julian assange por los
temas por las denuncias formulados que
después se demostraron que no eran tales
y había pruebas suficientes para
acreditar que era claramente un montaje
y decayó la
imputación y a pesar del esfuerzo que
nosotros hicimos para que fuese
adelante pero claro con unas garantías
mínimas de nord de extradición y no
entrega a eeuu y esas son las que nunca
se dieron por tanto son fue meramente
instrumental como después se ha
comprobado y lo que sí hemos comprobado
también y demostrado y actualmente está
en investigación es la propia audiencia
nacional en el juzgado central de
instrucción número 5 de la audiencia
nacional española que es cuál ha sido la
incidencia de los servicios de
inteligencia
estadounidenses en colaboración con la
empresa de seguridad española que
prestaba esa seguridad
de ecuador en londres hay evidencias
abrumadoras de
de la entrega de información sobre
julian sobre lo que se hacía sobre los
documentos sobre la estrategia de
defensa este 3 centra y eso también se
va a poner ya se ha puesto de manifiesto
ante la justicia británica y tendrán que
entrar a valorar esas circunstancias sí
y ya para finalizar esta conversación
señor garzón le quería preguntar las
posibilidades que creen tienen ustedes
para ganar este caso
pues bien yo creo que todavía hay jueces
en berlín como como dice es la anécdota
de federico el grande no todavía hay
jueces en gran bretaña y esperemos que
en algún momento entren en el fondo de
la cuestión que es la libertad de prensa
la libertad de información la
desproporción de las actuaciones la
incidencia de los servicios de
inteligencia la
exacerbación de medidas en contra de
este periodista y que todo esto que es
el fundamento de nuestra defensa y que
todavía la no ha entrado en ello lahey
core porque solamente entró a definir si
había riesgo de suicidio y de que el
trato sería y amable en eeuu se tiene
que ver por tanto si tienen que agotar
primero vamos a ver lo que dice el home
office cuya decisión también puede ser
recurrida después plantearemos todos y
cada uno de los argumentos para que
también sean valorados
fondo del asunto y no olvidemos que gran
bretaña forma parte del consejo de
europa y por tanto está sometida a la
doctrina y al enjuiciamiento en su
personal del tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos en donde sin lugar a
dudas plantearemos el caso con la
intención de que se analice de una vez
el fondo de la cuestión y es el la
agresión a derechos fundamentales entre
ellos el de la libertad de información y
acceso a la información claro señor
garzón gracias por su tiempo por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 para hablar sobre todo de este
caso de el fundador de wikileaks julian
assange para nosotros fue un gusto haber
conversado con usted de rosa muchas
gracias por compartir toda esta
información con nosotros le garantizamos
que desde aquí vamos a seguir muy de
cerca este